bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission où on ne va pas brassé que du
vent
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ces
caches à l'heure de la coop 26 et d'un
g20 particulièrement tourné sur le
climat on va s'interroger sur le futur
des énergies en france sur quoi faut-il
miser le nucléaire est il une énergie de
transition ou alors une énergie d'avenir
quel futur pour le secteur en france
comment répondre à nos besoins
énergétiques tout en prenant en compte
les défis environnementaux ce sont les
questions qui vont nous occuper olivier
ces vingt prochaines minutes bonjour
olivier bonjour et pour en parler nous
sommes avec nicolas meilleurs ingénieurs
et experts énergie bienvenue dans ces
caches merci à beaucoup d'être parmi
nous bonjour hydrogène nucléaire éolien
quelles énergies pour demain on fait le
tour avec le tiroir cash d'antoine
baisse
[Musique]
c'est un débat qui occulte pas mal
l'actualité ces derniers temps entre les
prix de l'énergie la coop 26 la campagne
présidentielle qui a démarré qu'elle
sera l'énergie du futur compatible avec
la sauvegarde de l'environnement et la
baisse des émissions de co2 pour
emmanuel macron il semble que ce soit le
nucléaire alors qu'en 2018 il annonçait
la fermeture de 14 réacteurs d'ici 2035
le triplement de l'éolien et la
multiplication par cinq du
photovoltaïque
il annonce le mois dernier dans le plan
d'investissement trans 2030 le
développement de réacteurs nucléaires de
petite taille innovant pour un milliard
d'euros et on attend une annonce d'ici
cette fin d'année de la construction de
nouveaux apn ou réacteur pressurisé
européen si vous préférez le nucléaire
est considéré par certains comme une
énergie d'avenir par d'autres comme une
énergie de transition vers des énergies
plus renouvelable d'autres encore
voudrait en sortir le plus tôt possible
dès 2030 en france le nucléaire c'est
près de 70 % du mix électrique une
énergie prise en étau entre les risques
d'accident qui terrifie comme ça a été
vu avec tchernobyl ou fukushima et le
peu de co2 calais mais tout en
fournissant beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup
plus que certaines énergies
renouvelables comme l'éolien par exemple
qui recueille de moins en moins
d'adeptes de par ses dommages sur les
paysages sont faibles rendement donc le
besoin de terres rares pour sa
construction ou son incompatibilité
présumés avec le secteur de la pêche
pour l'éolien marin mais c'était pas la
seule énergie renouvelable solaire
hydraulique biomasse elles sont
nombreuses et semble être l'avenir
puisque aujourd'hui 80% des
investissements mondiaux sur le secteur
de l'énergie se ferait sur le
renouvelable
voilà pour ce tour d'horizon une
première réaction peut être obligé pour
commencer à ce que vous venez d'entendre
dans le tiroir cash en direct comme
d'habitude si vous voulez les coop
ce sont des endroits où on fixe la date
de la prochaine coop
mais pas grand chose d'autre en fait et
on voit qu'il ya quand même pas de
stratégie parce que le tir haut à cash
la dit c'est à dire que en 2018 monsieur
macron dit quelque chose en 2021
visiblement il a changé d'avis je veux
dire on n'est pas on n'est pas sur un
cap qui est très claire oui je parle du
nucléaire et donc je m'étonne tout de
même qu' on n'est pas on soit pas fichu
d'avoir un président et un gouvernement
qui a sérieusement bosser le sujet et
qui
et qui change d'avis comme de chemise
donc évidemment ça va créer des
désordres puisque je vous rappelle
qu'une centrale nucléaire ne se
construit pas en trois mois et donc
là on en a pris pour pour dix ans si
vous voulez ou 15 ans donc évidemment il
faudrait tout de même que temps en temps
il prévoit autre chose que leur
réélection et qu' il est réellement une
vision et un et qu'on y aille et qu'on
fasse réellement des investissements au
lieu de mettre des patchs un petit peu
partout nicolas meilhan même question
oui dans les kops je partage ce crédit
olivier il faut quand même savoir que
les émissions de co2 n'ont jamais autant
augmenté au niveau mondial que depuis
qu'on essaie de faire baisser ce qui qui
est un peu gênant plus de 50% depuis les
premières coques sur des émissions de
co2 donc oui je pense qu'on fixe la
prochaine date mais il ya aussi quelques
petits fours peut-être qu'on parle des
performances de son jet puisque gens qui
n'en ont déjà été repartant jet bien
évidemment
c'est vrai que c'est des réunions as
inutile mais quand vous faites une cow
prod à 200 personnes il ya peu de
chances que vous mettiez d'accord sur
quoi que ce soit et ça c'est ça se
comprend facilement quand on revient sur
la france parle beaucoup de nucléaire en
france ce qui est très drôle en guinée
en france mais un peu tragique c'est que
quand on parle d'énergie tout de suite
c'est le nucléaire mais quand on parle
des preuves de prix d'énergie on parle
plus nucléaire pourquoi parce que
nucléaire c'est que la moitié du
problème c'est l'électricité l'autre
moitié c'est le pétrole pour transporter
et le gaz pour se chauffer se noue rien
les problèmes des prix donc on peut
continuer à parler de nucléaire de
renouvelables de savoir comment on va
remplacer une énergie décarbonée par une
autre décarbonés ce qui n'aura
probablement pas d'impact sur les sur la
coque bien évidemment en attendant parle
pas du problème et quand il arrive à
nous on colle des rustines le problème
c'est pétrole gaz on a eu un g20 avec un
gros volet consacré au climat vous
l'avais dit il ya la coop 26 en ce
moment à glasgow qui a été présenté à
commun est né un événement crucial pour
l'avenir de la planète notamment par le
secrétaire général de l'onu aujourd'hui
l'enjeu
dans le choix des politiques
énergétiques à mener c'est quoi est ce
que c'est d'avoir des sources d'énergie
qui répondent à la fois à nos besoins
tout en étant compatible avec les enjeux
environnementaux c'est ça la difficulté
aujourd'hui alors la difficulté
aujourd'hui déjà fait d'avoir un débat
sur le sujet un débat argumenté et fondé
en france ça n'est pas possible parce
que soit vous êtes pro nucléaire ça vous
êtes pro renouvelables dans les deux cas
vous parlez pas des problèmes qui sont
le pétrole et le gaz et donc on manque
un peu de pragmatique le club la
première chose c'est d'avoir un débat
sur ce sujet de savoir où sont nos
dépendances parce que par exemple ceux
qui sont tout nucléaire alors le
nucléaire c'est bien il ya des
contraintes par exemple le fait que
auparavant c'était nous qui entretenions
nous centrale
qu'alstom mais depuis ce sont des
américains est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on est
vraiment souverain quand c'est donald
trump ou bayonne qui décident de
l'entretien de nos 60 centrales
nucléaires c'est pas sûr et puis
nucléaire il ya d'autres problèmes et
des risques il rit sur les déchets mais
même sur l'approvisionnement d'uranium
de l'uranium n'y aura peut-être pas en
quantité infinie la france avait été un
des premiers pays à développer des
réacteurs de quatrième génération le
réacteur civil qui enlève cette
contrainte sur l'approvisionnement mais
finalement on a préféré prendre des
réacteurs américains pour des raisons
militaires dans les années 60 et 180 fin
des années 90 on a sept réacteurs de 4e
génération et on est une écolo se faire
plaisir qui ferme ce truc là et qui tue
la filière nucléaire française donc on a
on a on a un gros problème
parce qu'aujourd'hui même le nucléaire
on a des contraintes si vous voulez
qu'on va qu'on pourra pas à résoudre
rapidement
mais je suis d'accord le problème c'est
problème c'est l'hiver
problème c'est les verts c'est à dire
que beaucoup n'ont absolument rien
compris où on leur a demandé de ne rien
comprendre sur sûr c'est pas de là c'est
pas du conspirationnisme c'est
simplement l'un fait que aujourd'hui on
a on a un espèce de mots d'ordre qui est
de fermer les usines nucléaires mais
sans penser à ce que à comment on les
remplace et et pas se retrouver dans une
situation où on serait obligé de
remplacer les centrales nucléaires par
des centrales à charbon ce qui a priori
n'est pas ne va pas dans le bon sens
donc voilà enfin on est on a
l'impression qu'on marche sur la tête
c'est à dire que jamais on a un réel
plan sur la façon dont on va réellement
changer les choses et et avoir quelque
chose de 2,2 de réellement vers entre
guillemets
vous pour que d'aller plutôt que d'aller
inventer des espèces de moyens qui n'en
sont pas c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois
on regarde on j'écoutais jancovici ya
pas il n'ya pas très longtemps qui
disait que si on voulait fournir de
l'électricité aussi bien pour les
voitures que pour le les maisons ex
terra dans l'est et n'avoir que des
éoliennes il faudrait des éoliennes tous
les tous les kilomètres en france donc
ça ne peut pas fonctionner donc opposons
nous la question autrement c'est à dire
essayons d'être pragmatique et essayons
de all yeux de dépenser des milliards
dans des trucs qui ne fonctionne pas
peut-être que si on les dépenses est un
petit peu autrement sur la recherche par
exemple pour
retraiter les déchets nucléaires etc
peut-être qu'on aurait trouvé longtemps
ça veut dire est que pour vous le
nucléaire c'est c'est une énergie
d'avenir et non une énergie de
transition et vida mans une énergie
d'avenir donc parce que aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas mieux fassi si on veut
réellement fournir de l'électricité dans
les quantités dans lesquels on va être
obligé d'en fournir parce que si demain
on a tous des voitures électriques on
n'a pas d'eau on n'a plus de voiture qui
roule au pétrole il va falloir qu'il y
ait beaucoup d'électricité produite et
c'est pas avec avec l'éolien parce que
l'éolien ne se pilote pas parce que
l'éolien aujourd'hui on n'a pas encore
trouvé de quoi stocker cette électricité
et donc ça ne fonctionnera pas donc il
faut trouver autre chose et peut-être
que si on dépense est un peu moins pour
construire ces éoliennes qui finalement
ne servent pas à grand chose et qui ont
des rendements catastrophiques
c'est de l'ordre de 20% donc qui ont des
rendements catastrophiques
et bien ça serait peut-être plus
intelligente dépenser cet argent sur de
la recherche sur le
le nucléaire à mon avis nicolas meilhan
au niveau mondial 80% des nouveaux
investissements énergétiques se ferait
dans les énergies renouvelables olivier
évoqué l'éolien ya pas que ça comme
énergie renouvelable pourtant est loupé
un de pas investir dans ce secteur pour
un pays comme la france se serait pas un
peu loupé le train mais je pense que on
a aussi beaucoup d'investissements dans
les renouvelables et les renouvelables
ont leur rôle à jouer on a en france une
ressource qui est notamment une en
trouve devant qui est importante dans la
manche et donc effectivement on pourrait
pour ne pas dépendre à 100% du nucléaire
80% sur l'électricité éviter de mettre
tous ses oeufs dans le même panier et
avoir une partie de l'électricité qu'ils
puissent provenir de l'éolien en mer si
c'est rentable si les contraintes
associées il n'y a pas d'énergie
parfaite comme le rappelait antoine face
à ce vous avez l'éolien en mer il y aura
des problèmes avec la pêche l'éolien sur
terre grâce avec les gens le nucléaire
allant des déchets donc c'est toujours
un compromis n'a pas d'énergie parfaite
et donc on doit trouver le meilleur
compromis moi ce que j'aime bien c'est
le pragmatisme parle du royaume uni et
au royaume uni ils ont pas nos écolos
qu'est ce qu'ils disent de moi mettre
mon électricité ces trois piliers gaz de
schiste
nucléaire renouvelable
impossible à voir ce genre de
discussions en france qu'est ce qu'on
fait nous sur le gaz de schiste on
apporte des états unis on a été le
premier importateur mondial de gaz de
schiste par contre qu'est ce qu'on fait
en france mardi et qu'est ce qu'il yaa
par l'éolien dans les renouvelables ben
vous avez raison que la question si on
regarde les énergies décarbonées parce
que ce qui est in ce qui nous intéresse
a baissé les médecins ont dit on va
regarder le décarbonés énergie
hydraulique premières énergies
renouvelables on appelait ça la la
houille blanche 1 développé en france
ont été des champions là on a à peu près
utiliser tout le potentiel qu'on a sur
notre sol on va pas faire va pas
construire des montagnes donc se limiter
sur l'hydraulique on peut pas faire
grand chose au niveau mondial quelque
chose à voir mais ça reste limitée après
vous avez effectivement éolien pour le
coup qui roule à jouer mais qui va poser
des contraintes 1 n'a besoin de beaucoup
d espace pour le japon voilà on pourrait
couvrir le japon d'éoliennes ça vous
couvrira pas sa consommation d'énergie
donc
et puis ça consomme aussi des matières
premières
des métaux des terreurs mais pas que ça
ça consomme beaucoup plus d'acier est
beaucoup plus de ciment au kilowattheure
que vous allez généré qu'une centrale
nucléaire donc ça pose d'autres
contraintes et puis le photovoltaïque là
le problème de cette énergie c'est que
fonctionne le côté du soleil est souvent
le soleil c'est entre 11 heures et 14
heures et entre 11 heures et 14 heures
c'est pas forcément là on a le pic de
consommation donc il faut la stocker
sauf que l'électricité ça se stocke pas
bien un chiffre en allemagne où ils ont
mis des pâtes au foot panneaux
photovoltaïques partout et c'est que
quand le soleil brille en allemagne à
midi comme personne de la console ce
qu'est ce qu'ils en font ils l'exportent
il l'envoie chez les autres parce qu'ils
peuvent pas la consommer donc ce qu'il
faut surtout c'est un débat apaisé pas
idéologique je reprends l'exemple de
l'allemagne l'allemagne y sont ils sont
assez incroyables
pourquoi nos écolos sont anti nucléaire
parce qu'ils ont vu les allemands les
allemands icolo son arrivée au pouvoir
en 2000 avec fraudeurs grâce à ça je
crois d'or exempt d'une majorité il leur
a dit ok je ferme le nucléaire en 2022
ils ont fait le plus froid sens du style
montrer que ça c'est génial ils ont fait
pareil et c'est comme ça que d'ailleurs
françois hollande a été élu sur cette
promesse sauf que qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait en allemagne pour remplacer les
centrales nucléaires qui sont en train
de fermer à partir de 2005 ils ont dit
on va avoir un problème là si on ferme
les centrales qu'ils ont mis en place de
construction de nouvelles centrales à
charbon
2010en gala merkel écoutez ça fait dix
ans que j'entends cette histoire de coop
qui me parle de chez eux ne peut être
qu'on va plutôt favoriser le nucléaire
charbon pourtant là par la barre du
chardon dans le mix énergétique allemand
est en baisse depuis 2014 oui bien sûr
elle est en baisse mais elle est en
baisse et on est passé de 40% à 25 à 30
% avec un développement très fort des
énergies renouvelables 300 milliards
d'euros sur la table a priori on va
trouver l'argent magique avant nous donc
oui ça diminue vous en avez quand même
encore encore beaucoup est ce que je
veux dire c'est que l'allemagne 2 le
2011 six mois avant fukushima angela
merkel d'écouté g où je vous ai compris
au cob j'ai compris le message la
priorité c'est le co2 donc je décale de
dix ans la fermeture du parc nucléaire
et je vais faire mais d'abord mais c'est
en train à charbon six mois plus tard
fukushima girouette bon je re mais ma
fermeture en 2022 et je continue sur le
charbon donc on a un vrai on a un vrai
et un vrai sujet
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe notamment au
niveau mondial qui catastrophique pour
le climat c'est que avec les problèmes
des coûts de l'énergie la consommation
de charbon notamment en asie repart à la
hausse et pourrait battre des records
historiques 2021 2022 qui veut dire que
pour le climat on peut juste arrêter
d'en discuter arrêté l'école parce que
au moins au nikon haut misera tout le
co2 émis par les par les 200 jet mais si
on va marquer une courte pause et on
vient dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine quel
futur pour les énergies en france et
pour en parler nous sommes avec nicolas
meilhan ingénieurs et experts énergie on
va parler à présent du plan france 2030
présenté par emmanuel macron le 12
octobre dernier il s'agit d'un grand
plan d'investissements à hauteur de 30
milliards d'euros qui vise les steak les
secteurs dits et stratégiques sur ce
budget un milliard sera consacré au
nucléaire que ce soit pour les opèrent
ou les mini réacteurs appelés smr la
france continuera à avoir besoin du
nucléaire a estimé emmanuel macron un
postulat qui ne met pas tout le monde
d'accord investir de nouveau dans le
nucléaire serait être totalement à
rebours de ce qui se passe dans le monde
déclaration de yannick jadot le candidat
écologiste à la présidentielle elle chez
france info alors le nucléaire olivet
doit-il faire partie de l'avenir vous
l'avez dit oui selon vous comment
expliquer en revanche ce volte-face des
manuels macron vous védie d'ailleurs
nicolas mis en tout à l'heure emmanuel
macron la fermeture de fessenheim
c'était une promesse volante ça a été
fait par emmanuel macron aujourd'hui on
nous annonce qu'on va réinvestir dans le
nucléaire comment vous expliquez ce
volte-face
comme comme beaucoup de politiques c'est
une girouette donc
au gré du vent
il ne crée pas d'électricité mais il
change d'avis et donc voilà après la
déclaration de dj d'eau disent en choeur
de yannick pardon shadow qui dit qu'on
va à l'encontre
de du monde je rappelle que les chinois
ont décidé de construire 160 centrales
nucléaires et donc je ne crois pas qu'on
soit à l'envers de tête à l'envers des
allemands mais pas entendu et a gagné
80% des nouveaux investissements se font
dans le renouvelable est ce que c'est
pas aller à l'envers que d'investir dans
le nucléaire mais il coûte cher parce
que ça coûte cher et ça nous coûte cher
donc
on sponsorise en fait ce genre
d'activité alors beaucoup il voit
d'ailleurs un bon moyen de gagner très
vite de l'argent mais
malheureusement ça nous coûte à tous
beaucoup d'argent aujourd'hui nicolas
millions la part du nucléaire dans le
mix énergétique se situe aux alentours
de 70% l'objectif d'ici à 2035 c'est de
la réduire à 50% c'est faisable
aujourd'hui alors le dans le mix
électrique effectivement c'est 70% dans
le mix énergétique c'est la moitié 35%
juste pour bien sûr emmanuel macron je
ne crois pas qu'ils changent d'avis
parce qu'il a toujours deux avis un avis
ils sont venus à temps donc quand on est
en même temps je pense qu'il a plutôt
toujours été favorables nucléaire lui
même dans son for intérieur mais quand
en même temps on veut voir barbara
pompili au gouvernement on peut pas le
dire ouvertement que il a attendu le bon
moment pour pour faire ses annonces que
les prix augmentent
l'élection présidentielle les français
sont plutôt favorables nucléaire mais je
crois pas qu'il ait changé d'avis là
dessus
après sfr à baisser la part du nucléaire
à 50% en fait cet objectif étant
stupides ne voulant rien dire 50% de
quoi de combien bah je peux pas vous
dire s'il réalise tout pas puisque de
toute façon si vous voulez cela
l'objectif et n'a pas de sens
ce qui a du sens et de réfléchir à si on
veut réduire notre dépendance au
nucléaire aux américains donc réduire la
part du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité ça ça peut faire du sens
augmenter le renouvelable ça peut faire
du sens mais dans ce cas là il faut
parler plus tôt du besoin de notre
consommation c'est d'abord la
consommation qu'il faut réduire savoir
pour quels usages on va faire de
l'électricité et une fois qu'on l'aura
réduite on verra ce qu'on met en face si
ça nous permet de réduire la part du
nucléaire de fermer les centrales les
plus anciennes celles qui sont qui
n'était pas le cas de faits semaine fait
ce même été ancien même marché très bien
donc celles qui sont peut-être un peu
plus dangereuses entre guillemets de les
fermer très bien à condition que le
budget des ménages n'explose pas parce
que on aura beau bloquer des prix
l'électricité il ya quelqu'un qui paye à
la fin et je te paye c'est vous donc
aujourd'hui ce qui est important ce qui
n'est malheureusement pas dans france
relance on parle pas de la consommation
on parle pas de comment on va adapter
notre consommation pour la réduire en
2030 en france 2038 donc on parle de
faire image lee réacteur nucléaire de
petite taille donc ça c'est bien mais
faire émerger ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'on commence à travailler pour les
développer et après il faut les
construire donc là ce serait plutôt pour
le plan france 2040 et pas 2030
hydrogène verts
justement le grâce à ce plan et même
macron souhaite faire de la france le
pays leader dans l'hydrogène vers 2
milliards d'euros vont être débloqués
pour cette technologie dans le cadre de
ce plan au total c'est un plan d'un peu
plus de 7 milliards d'ici à 2030 qui va
être consacré à l'hydrogène verdes aussi
peut-on considérer cette énergie comme
une énergie du futur alors non enfin oui
l'hydrogène et l'énergie du futur et le
restera toujours en anglais ça marche
mieux hydro hydrogen at the great future
and always will have donc et après est
ce qu'on pourrait être leader des
hydroliennes oui parce qu'on sera les
seuls à le faire donc on sera leader
d'un marché qui n'intéresse personne
puisqu'il n'a pas d'avenir
merci à beaucoup à nicolas meilhan
d'être venu sur le plateau je rappelle
que vous êtes ingénieur et expert
énergie place aux questions cash
et on démarre avec le commentaire de
françois merveille et la réduction de
l'utilisation des énergies fossiles on
s'y met quand que deviennent la
croissance et la dette dans ce nouveau
contexte qui va nous être imposée tôt ou
tard et tôt serait le mieux pour nos
enfants
je sais pas peut-être à l'occasion de la
coop 72
basse à celui de jean dupont olivier
delamarche ne comprend clairement rien
on est dans l'économie il fait son
beurre en annonçant l'apocalypse mais
les marchés ne font que monter alors ça
c'est intéressant parce que comme
beaucoup
de gens un peu limité eh bien ils
pensent que le marché financier
c c'est comme penser que la queue remue
le chien et que c'est pas le chien qui
remue la queue si vous voulez donc comme
le marché financier se porte bien eh
bien il considère que donc l'économie se
porte comme un charme et bien non je
dois vous annoncer quelque chose
c'est toujours le chien qui remue la
queue et non pas la queue qui remue le
chien et donc qu'on finira par s'en
apercevoir
malheureusement que les choses ne vont
pas parce que simplement le cac 40 est
au plus haut mais restez sur le cac40 ça
va bien se passer merci olivier c'est la
fin de cette émission merci de votre
fidélité pour voir ou revoir nos
précédents numéros rendez vous sur notre
site internet à l'adresse rt france
point tv et n'oubliez pas de poser
toutes vos questions olivier delamarche
et de réagir à cette émission sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag rt cash
on se donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine et on se quitte avec vous pour
olivier et votre mot de la fin à écouter
ici brasser du vent fournissent et de
l'énergie il suffirait de laisser parler
les politiques et on en aurait beaucoup